gun is all right here comes the clue for
you
this seattle-based coffee chain was
named for the first mate in Moby Dick I
never knew my mother
what is Starbucks you know nothing Jon
Snow
but don't worry I can help
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory you know if
there's one thing I've learned from all
my years working on these videos it's
that in the game of theories you either
win or you die at the hands of angry
fanboys but who knows that was for game
theory maybe film theory viewers will be
more forgiving oh just wait till I talk
about Star Wars never mind
shameless promotion of game theory aside
the HBO show Game of Thrones has been an
absolutely massive hit because of its
stellar storytelling captivating
characters and well other things lots
and lots of other things but in all
seriousness with the fifth season
currently in progress this show has been
presenting us with unsolved mysteries
since episode 1 even the books have left
us in the dark and when getting ready to
theorize about this series there is no
better place to start than with the
mystery of Jon Snow's mother this detail
is so important to Game of Thrones that
when approached to adapt his books to TV
george RR martin the book's author ended
the interview asking for her true
identity now can we just take a minute
to appreciate the mental image of George
RR acting like the bridge keeper from
Monty Python what is your name
dan Weiss what is your quest adapt your
books to television what does the
identity of Jon Snow's mother apparently
these guys were able to answer correctly
and if they can figure it out so can we
now before we continue a warning we're
gonna be treading beyond the wall into
spoiler territory if you're up-to-date
with the show then you'll be fine if not
well beware ye who enter here there be
dragons and minor spoilers and
speculation for almost the first time I
get to talk about a work of fiction
that's actually in progress so this is
pretty cool
watch the show then watch this theory
then watch the rest of the show then go
back and watch this theory again to see
if I was right and you can know it here
first alright let's start with what we
know Jon Snow is the bastard son of am I
allowed to say bastard
isn't that like a bad word or something
watch out film Theory getting all pg-13
up in here Jon Snow is the born
out-of-wedlock son
Eddard Stark Lord of Winterfell and
warden of the North the story we know is
that John was born after a single night
of passion about 20 years ago and has
been raised by Lord stark in Winterfell
ever since we hear repeatedly from
various characters throughout the series
that John's personality resembles that
of a stark far more than any of Ned's
other true born children except for
maybe Arya so who are our suspects Ned
himself tells us the mothers name is a
woman named Wylla well he doesn't tell
us it's not like you went all meta and
broke the fourth wall or anything no he
says it to his close friend Robert
Baratheon a king of Westeros during the
second episode of the series the story
goes that she was a wet nurse who
somehow managed to charm Eddard into her
bed while he was away from home fighting
alongside Robert one thing leads to
another and nine months later out pops
the baby and Ned being a man of true
honor takes responsibility for the child
bringing him home to Winterfell boom
done open-and-shut case
cut and roll credits man these film
Theory episodes are easy okay so
obviously it's not as clear-cut as that
Eddard Stark is well was a pillar of
virtue I don't care how much junk y lo
was carrying in her trunk Ned was the
type of man who always stayed true to
his vows to what was just this is a guy
who would trade his head for his honor
literally in season one we see him
willing to die of starvation in a prison
cell because he won't lie about who the
next king of the realm rightfully is
Eddard just isn't the type of guy who
would dishonor his wife like that and
pulling a page from Reading Rainbow you
don't have to take my word for it
King Robert's brother Stannis backed me
up here in season five stating that
betting a tavern [ __ ] wasn't Ned
Stark's way and look at what Ned does
when Robert presses him to talk about
while off he nearly shuts down with
agony clearly in his eyes refusing to
speak anything but her name this is a
man who wouldn't have been able to cheat
on his wife even if he wanted to clearly
he's lying
you see loyal theorists Jon Snow's
mother isn't some naughty nurse or
random tavern wench but instead Ned's
deceased sister Lyanna stark oh ho ho
but I put it that way it makes it sound
way worse get your minds out of the
gutter this isn't a Searcy Jamie
situation stop typing your rage comments
Ned isn't an incestuous necrophiliac no
my theory is that Ned isn't John's
parent at all that John's mother is
Lyanna stark and that the father is
actually Rhaegar Targaryen now if you've
never seen the show you're probably
asking who's that and if you have seen
the show and you're probably still
asking who's that because seriously who
is that there are so many darn
characters in the show whose names are
impossible to remember seriously
Roose Bolton I mean who took any notice
than that guy before the end of season 3
am i right ok so who is Rhaegar outside
of being the guy whose name is literally
impossible to type correctly well he's
probably the most important character
will never meet on the show considering
he's dead but we do know a lot about him
already
he was Daenerys Targaryen oldest brother
and heir to the throne of Westeros we
also hear in bits and pieces throughout
season 1 that he kidnapped and raped
Liana and that Robert who was engaged to
her started a war called Robert's
rebellion to bring her back at the end
of the rebellion he ends up killing
Rhaegar but when they try to rescue
lianna she's already dying
lying in a bed of her own blood but
beyond Leone array gars death actually
had huge repercussions resulting in the
Targaryen family being ousted from the
throne Daenerys and her brother having
to flee the realm and Robert Baratheon
becoming King so a pretty big deal for a
guy that we've never met so what makes
me say that we've been lied to and that
Jon Snow's parents are two characters
that are already dead that we'll never
meet let me explain although there have
been hints here and there last week's
episode actually gives us the strongest
clue we've yet seen on the show
confirming this theory there's a crucial
scene that takes place in the crypts
below Winterfell between Ned's eldest
daughter Sansa and the sleaziest guy in
the kingdom of Westeros Lord Baelish
while they walk through the Hall of
fallen Starks Sansa mentions that her
father never talked about his sister
Lyanna and that others said that she was
quite beautiful this prompts Lord
Baelish to tell a story about the only
time he ever saw Ned's sister he was at
a great tournament where everyone who
was anyone was in
tendance basically it was like Westeros
is coachella at the end of the
tournament it was Rhaegar Targaryen who
stood victorious and as his prize he was
given a crown of blue roses to give to
the woman he believed to be the most
beautiful in all of the Seven Kingdoms
so weird prize but hey go with it so of
course everyone expected him to give it
to his wife Elia Martell cuz you know
it's his wife but he actually rode past
her to give the crown too you guessed it
Lyanna stark man that had to be an
awkward horse ride back to the old
stronghold riot shortly thereafter he
kidnaps her and well we know the rest of
the story or do we did this guy really
just kidnap rape and kill Liana because
he thought she was pretty something
tells me you don't romantically and
chivalrously give a crown of flowers to
a girl if that's what you're planning to
do a few weeks later and honestly I'm
not the only one who thinks so sure
Robert Baratheon made bad-mouth Rhaegar
on the show but everyone else gives the
guy glowing reviews surge or appraises
the late Prince when he discusses
Rhaegar with his sister Daenerys Rhaegar
fought valiantly Rhaegar fought nobly
Rhaegar died sir Barristan Selmy one of
the noblest and most honorable people on
the show behind Ned Stark eagerly tells
stories about how considerate and
generous Rhaegar was like I never liked
killing you loved to sing you and what
did you do with the money well one time
he gave it to the next missile down the
street one time he gave it to an
orphanage in flea bottom one time we got
horribly drunk even Ned has nothing but
kind words to say about him in the books
which is odd when you're referring to
the man who supposedly stole your sister
and had a direct hand in her death isn't
it much more likely that this kidnapping
story is simply a cover for two kids who
fell in love and did something
incredibly romantic and incredibly
stupid by running away together we get
an additional detail in the books that
after the supposed kidnapping Rhaegar
hides leon away in a place named the
tower of joy really the tower of joy
subtle much Arar seriously though these
guys are fighting a war for him and he's
hanging out in the belfry of banging the
minaret of manoj
parapet of pleasure after ray gars death
the story we know is that Ned races up
the tower of titillation to free Liana
only to find her dying in a bed of blood
with her last words being promised me
Ned now think about this a bed of blood
yes it could be Rhaegar killing the girl
that childbirth can also be a pretty
messy business then she asks Ned to make
a promise
could it be perhaps a promise to raise
her newborn child or to take it one step
further to keep the child safe by
keeping his true parentage secrets I
mean you know Robert would totally freak
out of his beloved fiancee had a baby
with another man Robert just started a
rebellion against a royal dynasty in an
attempt to get her back oh sorry we were
in love that ain't gonna cut it
it would make sense that Ned would have
to claim the child as his own to cast
off suspicion then when Ned returns to
Winterfell with the baby John no one
would ever know the boy's true parentage
makes a whole lot of sense to me
additionally we hear that when Ned rode
for the tower of joy he and his
companions didn't find Liana alone no
three of the Kingsguard were there
standing watch over the lady Stark
including the Lord Commander himself why
would they be there instead of fighting
or swearing allegiance to the new king
or most importantly of all protecting
the only two remaining Targaryen
Daenerys and her brother as they escaped
the country probably because they were
busy protecting another Targaryen a baby
the heir to the Iron Throne of the
kingdom Jon Snow need more proof ever
wonder why Ned had such an extreme
reaction to Robert trying to assassinate
Daenerys back in season one how about
the disgust and urgency he shows when
Robert says he'll kill every Targaryen
he can get his hands on stakes are high
because Jon Snow would also have
Targaryen blood meaning his life would
be at risk or how about some more super
recent evidence like the awkward scene
between Jon and the red woman at the
wall in season 5 where she attempts to
seduce him the only times she's done
this in the past was with men who
possess royal blood Stan
and Gentry and now her latest target Jon
Snow with the royal blood of the
Targaryen score Seng through his veins
but the biggest smoking gun of all comes
from none other but Ned Stark himself or
rather his actor Sean Bean in an air
view with vulture being admit that Ned's
quote definitely got some unfinished
business that needs to be resolved there
I'm obviously not Jon Snow's dad and you
need that to be revealed at some point
don't you end quote
that my dear theorists is what you call
an open-and-shut case or a desperate
need for actors to sign NDA's one of the
two so if this theory does prove to be
true what does this mean for the future
plot lines of the show well if Rhaegar
and Lyanna got married before john was
born
he'd be the rightful heir to the Iron
Throne even more so than Daenerys which
makes another odd scene in the show make
a whole lot of sense we've seen this
image a few times throughout the series
most notably is one of the visions Danny
sees in the house of the undying the
king's throne room covered in snow it
could be a literal reference to Jon Snow
which is a bit on the nose but whatever
it's television
or it could just represent that both
Daenerys and the true king of the realm
have a connection with the cold north
perhaps it's foreshadowing that before
the end of the series Jon Snow will be
sitting on that throne it's kind of
poetic in a way the north and the wall
and the Starks symbolize ice cold and
harsh the South and King's Landing in
the Targaryen symbolise fire hot and
passionate if Jon is the merging of
these bloodlines then his truly would be
a Song of Ice and Fire but hey that's
just a theory a film theory
and cut we've got another game of
Thrones theory in the works in time for
the season 5 finale that trust me you're
not gonna want to miss so Pullen Eddard
Stark and behead that subscribe button
to make sure you're the first to show
off how smart you are to your friends or
if the how nerdy whatever screw them
it's a good show they should watch it
now welcome back to the super amazing
end card
where I give you a question you vote I
tell you the results next time and you
get taken to the channel page where you
watch all film Theory episodes today an
obvious question I want to know who is
your favorite character from Game of
Thrones there are definitely a lot but
the obvious frontrunner or Arya Tyrion
and Daenerys so let's choose between
them for me it's a tough call between
Ahri and Tyrion anyway click on one to
choose and next time find out who truly
wins this game of Thrones